when you think about your risk tolerance
for failure
how far are you willing to fail well i
mean unfortunately unfortunately i felt
quite a bit
yeah you know but i understand that's
actually part of the process of
succeeding
i'm not one that really believe in
failure i believe you have setbacks
and you know you have to learn from
those you have to learn what
are those landmines that can be avoided
the next time
what are those pitfalls you have to
learn from that stuff
so you're not welcome those things it's
a part of life but are you prepared to
like
really fail it's something totally new
like what if you're just a
vc then i'm like ubc yeah you know and
then
i work at it and then i'm not a vc the
next
yeah you know whenever it happens yeah
listen i
my first year in the league on national
tv at 18 years old and i shot
five straight air balls in the playoffs
in front of millions of people
yeah i think my time remember is pretty
high yeah yeah i think i'm all right